[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer der
Bundeskanzler sagt Deutschland geht
gestärkt aus der Krise hervor wenn es
denn nur eine wäre und wenn auch nur für
eine dieser Krisen ein Ende in Sicht
wäre Inflation Energieknappheit
Klimawandel Flüchtlinge und vor allem
der Krieg der Krieg in der Ukraine vor
einem Jahr über vielen russische Truppen
das Land ein bitterer Jahrestag wie er
Deutschland aus dieser multikrise
herausführen will das frage ich heute
den Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz Herrscher
als guten Abend
heute vor einem Jahr der Vorabend des
Überfalls können Sie sich noch erinnern
was sie wann erfahren haben
ich kann mich erinnern weil das ja den
ganzen Tag und auch die Tage vorher ein
großes Thema war
wann beginnt der Krieg der immer
wahrscheinlicher geworden war nach der
redete der russische Präsident dann auch
gehalten hatte und nachts ist es dann so
dass mich das Kanzleramt angerufen hat
und ich dann auch mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten telefoniert hat und sie
haben was empfunden
waren sie irgendwie vorbereitet große
Überraschung Schreck Sorge es ist ein
furchtbarer Krieg der da begonnen hat
und das war sofort klar natürlich war es
auch so dass die Tage vorher wie ich
eben schon gesagt hat man spüren konnte
dass die Gefahr größer geworden ist und
deshalb war es wirklich bedrückend aber
noch mal fest zu sein jetzt ist es
wirklich passiert denn das ist ja wie
ich gesagt habe eine Zeitenwende es hat
gibt wieder Krieg in Europa das dann mit
dem größten Territorium eine
hochgerüstete Atommacht Russland
überfällt sein Nachbarland dass man mit
dem zweitgrößten Territorium in der in
Europa und das ist wirklich etwas sehr
bedrückendes und sehr gefährliches
sie kennen die letzten Äußerungen des
ukrainischen Präsidenten er klagt immer
noch Herr Scholz er müsste sie ständig
überzeugen und Druck machen und zwar
auch nach der Entscheidung
über die kampfpflanze ich muss Druck
machen der Ukraine zu helfen und ihn
ständig überzeugen dass diese Hilfe
nicht für uns ist sondern für die
Europäer
das ist vom 9.2 dieses Jahres warum
zweifelt er glauben sie immer noch an
ihrem Engagement Norbert zweifelt nicht
übrigens ist so dass unsere Gespräche
immer sehr freundlich stattfinden so
dass ich nicht wirklich berichten kann
was das Druck machen sein soll
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass wir als
Deutsche ja mittlerweile ganz vorne
anstehen wenn es darum geht die Ukraine
zu unterstützen nicht nur finanziell und
humanitär sondern eben auch wenn es um
Waffenlieferung geht und das müssen wir
hier auch noch mal uns klar machen nach
dem russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
haben wir mit einem Jahrzehnte langen
Tabu gebrochen und Waffen in einem
Kriegsgebiet geliefert das habe ich
wenige Tage nach Kriegsausbruch im
Deutschen Bundestag erläutert und wir
haben gleichzeitig entschieden dass wir
unsere Bundeswehr verstärken dass wir
zwei Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
Verteidigung ausgeben und ein
Sondervermögen auf den Weg bringen um
das zu ermöglichen wenn wir auf jeden
Fall noch reden auch mit welchen
Konsequenzen wenn sie sich so engagieren
und trotzdem der schwarze Peter bei
ihnen immer landet haben sie dann zu
wenig Verbündete unter den Verbündeten
herr Scholz wir sind
fest entschlossen immer im Einklang mit
unseren Verbündeten zu handeln und
deshalb wäre ich mich auch gegen alle
diejenigen die vorschlagen dass man
vorbrechen soll dass man ein Alleingang
Wagen soll oder etwas ähnliches es geht
schon darum koordiniert vorzugehen und
alle wichtigen Entscheidungen die wir
getroffen haben haben wir mit unseren
engsten Verbündeten abgestimmt
insbesondere mit den Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika was mir persönlich sehr sehr
wichtig ist aber das gilt für viele der
Waffen die wir oft als erste und in
manchen Fällen sogar als einzige zur
Verfügung stellen wir haben entschieden
nachdem es am Anfang um Schulter
gestützte Panzer Abwehr Waffen ging dass
wir zum Beispiel mit mit der
Panzerhaubitze Unterstützung leisten
dass wir Gattungen noch mal aufzählen
ich wollte so gerne von Ihnen wissen ob
sie eine Erklärung dafür haben warum ja
ein britischer Historiker Timis sogar
ein Wort erfunden hat für das was sie
tun nämlich das und möchte dahinter
erklärt wissen dass man etwas verspricht
und dann wenigstens lange damit zögert
und sie haben in einer Sendung des ZDFs
bei was nun
darauf eine eigene Übersetzung gefunden
und trotzdem hören diese Beschwerden ja
nicht auf vielleicht können wir noch die
Übersetzung von scholzing ist
Deutschland macht das meiste
warum hagelte es dann so viel Kritik von
unseren Partnern
Berlin sollte die Handlungen anderer
Staaten nicht schwächen oder sabotieren
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass die Deutschen die die
Panzer ja herstellen auch mitmachen
werden und liefern
die Erwartungen der zeitenwände lassen
Deutschland keine Zeit wir brauchen sie
jetzt wir brauchen jetzt die Führung von
Deutschland die Ukraine braucht das
Litauen braucht das wenn wir Sicherheit
in Europa wollen
also wenn sie sich so engagieren Herr
Bundeskanzler warum geht das dann immer
so gegen sie man könnte ja auch immer
nur immer die Frage könnte ich auch
zurückstellen denn tatsächlich ist es
doch so dass wenn man die Wirklichkeit
betrachtet Deutschland vorne ansteht wir
liefern auch wenn Sie die Aufzählung
nicht so gerne mögen aber wir liefern
konkret das allermeiste und sind vorne
dabei die USA sind natürlich viel mehr
engagieren als viel größeres Land aber
das was Deutschland tut ist oft als
erstes geliefert worden ist oft als
einziges geliefert worden und ist immer
etwas das sehr wirksam ist bei der
Verteidigung der Ukraine aber eins
bleibt nicht irgendwelche Rufe von
irgendwem ob nun auf der nationalen oder
internationalen Bühne entscheiden
darüber wann wir uns entscheiden sondern
die enge Abstimmung die Vorbereitung und
das will ich hier auch ganz klar sagen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes können sich darauf verlassen dass
ich mich nicht Kämpfe machen lassen
werde von all den vielen Interviews von
den öffentlichen aufrufen von den
Erklärungen sondern dass es gut
vorbereitete wohl abgestimmte und wohl
abgewogene Entscheidung bleiben das ist
in einer solchen Situation etwas dass
man von einem Regierungschef erwarten
darf sie sagen wohl abgestimmt auf zwei
Dinge muss ich noch mal rekorieren sie
sagen immer als erste und als einzige
ich glaube das ist zu hinterfragen weil
mit den heldeninnen waren wir vielleicht
die ersten aber bei den Mardern und bei
den Haubitzen waren wir dass sie hier
nicht
abgestimmt jetzt merken Sie Herr Scholz
dass in dieser kampfpanzerfrage gar
nicht so viele mit dabei sind die immer
gesagt haben wir müssen jetzt unbedingt
nach den Schützenpanzern auch zu den
Kampfpanzern kommen also war das dann
nicht so gut abgestimmt oder sagen Sie
haben die auch den Bundeskanzler
Deutschlands benutzt um sich eigentlich
hinter ihnen zu verstecken nein ja wenn
Sie das jetzt schildern das ist nicht so
viele sind die obwohl sie vorher laut
gerufen haben jetzt mitmachen beschreibt
das ja ein Stück Realität
aber vielleicht ist das auch ein Hinweis
darauf warum das genau richtig ist so zu
machen wie wir wie ich das mache nämlich
miteinander sich zu koordinieren mit den
USA zum Beispiel und bestimmte
Entscheidungen so zu treffen dass sie
funktionieren und was das Hinterfragen
betrifft gestatten Sie mir dann doch
eine Bemerkung ihres Tee ist ein
deutsches System das liefern nur wir als
wir die Panzerhaubitzen geliefert haben
sind wir mit anderen vorweg marschiert
als wir das gemacht haben mit dem Panzer
ist es etwas was nur wir zur Verfügung
stehen wir sind diejenigen die sehr
helfen wenn es darum geht jetzt Patrick
Systeme zur Verfügung zu stellen als es
um Schützenpanzer und jetzt Kampfpanzer
ging waren wir auch vorne dabei trotz
der ganzen aufgerichte Diskussionen und
deshalb ist auch mein Rad an alle dass
man vielleicht die Art und Weise der
Diskussion ein bisschen ändert und
darauf setzt das in einer so schwierigen
Frage es nicht richtig ist aufgeregt von
Presseerklärung zu Pressekonferenz zu
eilen sondern das zu tun was jetzt
wirklich für mich wichtig ist ich frage
ja warum sie so kritisiert werden herr
Scholz und das verstehen sie weil man
möchte verstehen warum diese
osteuropäische Kritik bleibt in dieser
kampfpanzerdebatte haben sie Joe Biden
den amerikanischen Präsidenten an ihre
Seite bekommen er hat sie am Ende
unterstützt eben auch die berühmten
Abrams zu liefern und nicht nur den
Bradley also den amerikanischen
Schützenpanzer sie sehen das als Sieg
wie oft können sie sich gegenüber dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten einen solchen
Sieger erlauben das sind jetzt ihre
Worte und nicht meine die ich auch nicht
wählen würde sondern wir haben uns immer
abgestimmt als z.B nur Deutschland
Großbritannien und die USA mehrfach
Raketenwerfer zur Verfügung gestellt
haben haben wir uns darüber abgestimmt
das ist auch kein Alleingang der USA zum
Beispiel gewesen und so ist es bei
vielen dieser einzelne Entscheidung
gewesen und so wird es auch bei allen
künftig noch zu treffenden
Entscheidungen sein und ich beharre
darauf dass wir genau so vorgehen dass
wir keine Alleingänge machen und dann
muss man aushalten dass einige eben mit
ihrer täglichen Pressekonferenz ein
bisschen warten müssen bis die
Entscheidung fallen
welches noch mal sind die Länder von
denen Sie jetzt das Gefühl haben die
haben anders gesprochen
Dänemark
Frankreich vielleicht die Niederlande
viele Länder in Europa tun was und
leisten was sie können und natürlich ist
klar
ich glaube schon dass es unsere Aufgabe
als Deutsche ist mit einem als größtes
Land mitten in der Europäischen Union
mit der größten Bevölkerung natürlich
auch mit den größten wirtschaftlichen
Möglichkeiten und auch einer trotz allem
was wir für die Zukunft uns vorgenommen
haben sehr leistungsfähigen Bundeswehr
dass wir
einen großen Beitrag leisten das ist
schon etwas was alle von uns erwarten
können und das machen wir auch und wir
hoffen dass möglichst viele immer
mitziehen im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten
die Panzer sind noch nicht da da heißt
es jetzt schon Kampfflugzeuge für die
Ukraine sie sagen diese Frage stelle
sich nicht stellt sie sich noch nicht
oder stellt sie sich überhaupt nicht
Debatte macht keinen Sinn eben haben wir
noch erörtert dass nicht alle schon
dabei sind die von ihnen vorher selbst
geforderten Kampfpanzer mit zur
Verfügung zu stellen das ist die Aufgabe
die wir jetzt haben und es ist ja doch
sehr klar was sowohl aus den USA von
Präsidenten als auch von mir und anderen
in Deutschland dazu gesagt worden ist
das ist eine Debatte die wirklich für
das was gerade stattfindet überhaupt
keinen Sinn macht wir müssen jetzt
sicherstellen können dass sich die
Ukraine gegen den fruchtbaren Angriff im
Osten der Ukraine wären kann und dazu
leisten genau die Waffen die wir zur
Verfügung stellen den notwendigen
beitragen keine deutschen PIL Menschen
über der Ukraine sie sagen keine
Flugverbotszone darauf verweisen Sie
diese Fragen stellt sich im Moment mit
den Piloten tatsächlich nicht mit den
deutschen aber nato-generals deutenberg
sagt jetzt wird auch über Flugzeuge
diskutiert was sagen Sie ihm
ich sage das gleiche was ich ihnen eben
gesagt habe diese Frage macht
gegenwärtig und macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn wir sollten uns mal das darauf
konzentrieren was jetzt in dieser ganz
konkreten Situation zu Verteidigung der
Ukraine notwendig ist und das sind genau
die Dinge die wir jetzt tun und unsere
Verbündeten auch beisteuern 95 Prozent
der Menschen in diesem Land sehr Scholz
machen sich Sorgen dass es eine größere
befasstheit der deutschen also ein
Involvierung der Deutschen in diesen
Krieg geben kann und auf der anderen
Seite wünscht man sich von ihnen dass
sie einen Satz sagen nämlich dass die
Ukraine
gewinnen muss
die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen
deswegen darf die Ukraine auf keinen
Fall verlieren das heißt die Ukraine
muss gewinnen ich hoffe sehr dass
Bundeskanzler das zum Ausdruck bringt
das war der neue ukrainische Botschafter
in Berlin er hat ein Bekenntnis von
Ihnen gefordert herr Scholz dass sie der
Ukraine gegenüber diesen Satz sagen der
offensichtlich ihrem
Verteidigungsminister und ihre
Außenministerin leichter über die Lippen
geht das ja kein Problem ich will Dir
klar sagen worum es aus meiner Sicht
geht nämlich dass wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass die Ukraine ihre Unabhängigkeit
ihre Integrität ihre staatliche
Souveränität verteidigen kann und auch
die Freiheit darum geht es ja auch und
das ist das was wir gewährleisten wollen
und ich lege Wert darauf mich präzise
auszudrücken nämlich zu sagen was ist
das was wir hier möglich machen wollen
und das ist genau das was ich eben
beschrieben habe deshalb unterstützen
wir
einem großen und bisher ungekannten
Ausmaß die Ukraine auch bei ihrer
Verteidigung und indem wir das tun und
das so tun
ist es geben wir auch die Antwort auf
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die sie am
Anfang ihres Satzes angesprochen haben
nämlich die sich Sorgen machen wir
werden alles dafür tun dass dieser Krieg
nicht sich auswächst zu einem Krieg
zwischen Russland und der NATO das
werden wir mit allem was wir können
verhindern und deshalb werden wir immer
Entscheidungen treffen die uns
ermöglichen die Ukraine zu unterstützen
aber die eben diese Eskalation
ausschließen
keiner wünscht sich das das ist klar der
Philosoph jürgen habermaß hat sich
gemeldet in der vorletzten Woche und
auch gesagt es ist aus seiner Sicht ein
wichtiger Gedanke nicht verlieren zu
wollen also die Ukraine nicht verlieren
zu lassen dass das ganz nicht nur ein
irgendwie formulierungsunterschied ist
also eine rhetorische sondern wirklich
auch ein
inhaltlicher sie wollen und das ist kein
Pazifismus ist das ist einen Unterschied
gibt zwischen dem und dem nicht
verlieren wenn der polnische Präsident
moraviewski sagt Deutschland versuche
immer so ein bisschen halbschwanger zu
sein und sich immer eine Tür offen zu
halten
hat er dann einen eine Formulierung
gefunden die wird Ihnen jetzt nicht
schmecken aber für das was die Deutschen
machen eben nicht zu sagen die Ukraine
muss diesen Krieg gewinnen es muss
gelingen Putin aus diesem Land
herauszutreiben und die Ukraine muss
gewinnen hier ist meine Frage gestalten
sie mir das ein bisschen lächerlich zu
finden wenn man sieht wie viel
Deutschland tut und dass wir vorne
anstehen in Europa zum Beispiel dann
macht das ja eigentlich keinen
besonderen Sinn sich über die Größe und
die Ernsthaftigkeit des deutschen
Engagements zu mokieren oder
irgendwelche Zweifel daran zu haben das
ist auch nicht in Ordnung im Blick auf
all diejenigen die sich da sehr viel
Mühe geben dass das möglich wird und im
übrigen auch
im Hinblick darauf dass es ja auch
Deutschland als Land ist die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger dieses Landes die ja einen
Beitrag dazu leisten dass das möglich
wird weil wir unsere Mittel und
Unmöglichkeiten einsetzen dass wir die
Unterstützung gewährleisten können ich
bin überzeugt dass das einfach nicht
vernünftig ist dass man ein so großes
Engagement dann immer wieder in Abrede
stellt und es ist auch etwas was
man nicht auf sich sitzen lassen muss
und schon gerade wenn wir sehen dass es
jetzt sogar Mühe macht alle dazu zu
bewegen dass Sie die von Ihnen selbst
geforderten Aktivitäten auch tatsächlich
Unternehmen fällt das doch ein bisschen
schwer das als etwas Vernünftiges in der
Diskussion zu begreifen und wenn noch
mal hämorrer wird gesagt er wirft ihnen
persönlich vor immer noch daran zu
glauben mit Russland nach dem Krieg
wieder zur Tagesordnung übergehen zu
können das ist ja ein herber Vorwurf
noch mal woher kommt dieses Misstrauen
sie sagen dass sie viel tun sie tun ist
vielleicht nicht immer als Erster um es
vorsichtig zu formulieren es gab bei
vielen Dingen eine sehr lange Diskussion
die Umstände haben sie geschildert warum
bleibt aber in Europa bei unserem
nächsten Nachbarn ein solches Misstrauen
erstmal in Europa existiert keinen
Misstrauen viele verstehen ganz genau
was wir tun
und deshalb macht es vielleicht auch
Sinn die Debatte vernünftig einzuordnen
wir haben immer akzeptiert dass unser
nächster Nachbarn eigene Diskussionen
hat die sich manchmal auch auf unser
Land beziehen und gar nichts mit dem was
wir tun oder nicht tun zu tun haben ich
wünschte mir dass die lange Tradition
guter Beziehung die wir zwischen
Deutschland und Polen haben auch in der
Zukunft sich weiterentwickelt aber
beschränke mich mal darauf das zu sagen
was der Fall ist deutschland muss sich
an dieser Stelle von niemandem Vorwürfe
anhören denn wir sind diejenigen die
sehr sehr viel machen und das eben auch
mehr als viele viele andere sie sagen
Herr Scholz der Rückzug der Russen
sollte Voraussetzung sein für
Verhandlungen das haben sie in einem
Bürgerforum in Marburg gesagt in dem
Augenblick in dem sie erkennen lassen
dass der Weg ein Truppenrückzug ist in
dem Augenblick ist der Weg für Gespräche
mit der Ukraine frei
wohin sollten sich die Russen
zurückziehen wohin sollten sie sich
zurückziehen reicht diese Linie vom 24.2
ich habe von Anfang an gesagt dass die
Frage was der Inhalt einer Verständigung
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland ist
nicht von uns und von außen
diktiert werden kann aber das ist doch
offensichtlich Russland kann nicht
darauf setzen dass es ein diktatfrieden
durchsetzen kann es kann nicht darauf
setzen dass einfach irgendwie
die Linie wo die Kriegsverlauf
gegenwärtig ist festgefroren wird und
der Rest dann mehr oder weniger
annektiert werden kann sondern es geht
nur in dem Russland versteht dass es
Truppen zurückziehen muss dass wir
tatsächlich eine Verständigung
ermöglichen und das ist das was ich
immer wiederhole übrigens auch in den
vielen vielen Gesprächen die ich mit dem
russischen Präsidenten führe denn wir
sind ja sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung
aber es müssen ja ein paar Leute mal
kommen und ihm auch noch widersprechen
das wird ja in seinem unmittelbaren
Umfeld kaum passieren kann passieren und
danach hätte ich sie als nächstes
gefragt hoffen sie eines fernen Tages
darauf dass Vladimir Putin sagt ich
ziehe mich zurück das war ein großer
Irrtum oder dass er sagt ich gebe auf
oder womit rechnen Sie wenn Sie über
diese Dinge nachdenken im Augenblick
müssen wir feststellen dass der
russische Präsident
unvermindert die Aggression fortsetzt
und
dann im Laufe des Krieges nachdem er
seine ganzen Ziele nicht erreicht hat
vor Kiew gescheitert ist seine Truppen
neu gruppieren musste dann im Osten den
Angriff begonnen hat der aber auch nicht
zu dem von ihm gewünschten Erfolg
geführt hat dass er am Ende auch nicht
durchkommen wird das muss er irgendwann
verstehen und das ist ja auch der Grund
warum wir diese große Unterstützung für
die Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen damit
dieser Moment eintritt nur jetzt ist das
nicht er hat dann eine sogenannte Teil
mobil machen in Russland angeordnet
nachdem er Wochen und Monate lang vorher
von einer spezialoperation gesprochen
hat und in Russland auch den Eindruck
erweckt hat als ob dass die russische
Bevölkerung praktisch gar nicht berühre
dass da ein Krieg geführt werde das
konnte auch nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten
und die Wahrheit ist ja das in diesem
Krieg nicht nur unglaublich viele
Schäden in der Ukraine entstanden sind
unglaubliche Zerstörung von Häusern von
Städten von Dörfern von Infrastruktur
das unglaublich viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger der Ukraine getötet worden sind
von russischen Bomben Kinder Frauen
Männer junge und alte sondern auch
Soldaten gestorben sind viele viele
ukrainische Soldaten und eben auch sehr
sehr viele russische Soldaten er hat das
Leben dieser jungen Männer gefährdet für
seinen imperialistischen Traum und der
muss Enden indem er einsieht dass das
nichts wird Wesley Clark an general den
wir alle noch erinnern sagt dass das
eben eine Besonderheit der Russen sei
dass er wenn Sie merken wie groß
eigentlich ihre eigenen Verluste sind
gegebenenfalls als ganze Nationen dann
in diesen Kampf gehen können und in
diesen Krieg gehen können Mark Melle der
us-generalstaatschef ist zu zitieren mit
dem Satz dass er eben auch nicht davon
ausgeht dass es gelingen wird die Russen
vollständig aus dem Territorium der
Ukraine zu drücken das heißt
sie könnten auch auf andere verweisen
wenn sie sagen am Ende werden wir einen
Friedensschluss haben der gar nicht
bedeuten kann dass inklusive der Krim
alle aus der Ukraine raus sind weil sie
diese Sorge haben dass das nicht zu
schaffen sein wird Herr Scholz also
rechnen Sie auch mit einem Kompromiss
nochmal die Frage was der Gegenstand
einer solchen Verständigung sein wird
muss die Ukraine entscheiden das werden
wir von unserer Hilfe und die kommt
entweder rechtzeitig genug oder sie
kommen von außen festlegen darauf können
sich die Ukraine auch immer verlassen
und das will ich gerne auch dazu sagen
im Hinblick auf die immer neu
herangeschafften Truppen ist es ganz
wichtig dass wir auch die Botschaft
zurücksenden wir werden in unserer
Unterstützung nicht nachlassen und die
Ukraine kann sich auch darauf verlassen
dass wir eher so lange helfen werden wie
das not nötig und notwendig ist aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir alles
unternehmen um Eskalation zu vermeiden
deshalb zum Beispiel bin ich sehr
bewusst auch nach Peking gereisten habe
mit dem chinesischen Präsidenten
gesprochen und wir beide haben dort in
Peking erklärt dass der Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen in diesem Krieg eine rote
Linie ist die nicht überschritten werden
darf das war ganz wichtig und hat dazu
beigetragen dass wenige Tage später bei
dem Treffen der G20 Staaten Indonesien
das als international die Linie
festgehalten worden ist und so müssen
wir dafür so müssen wir dafür sorgen
tragen das ist eben nicht zu einer
weiteren Eskalation kommt und
gleichzeitig deutlich machen dass es
keinen drin hat diesen falschen
gescheiterten Weg weiterzugehen mit
immer mehr Waffen immer mehr Soldaten
deren Leben man gefährdet zu versuchen
diese russische Eroberung doch noch zum
Ziel zu führen das wird und soll nicht
gehen wie weit ist die große Frage und
darf nicht auch die jure in jedem Fall
zu der Verteidigung eines angegriffenen
Landes dann gehören mit ihrer
Verteidigung das Territorium des
ergresses zu erreichen das ist ja aber
bisher immer ausgeschlossen worden und
sie schließen das nach wie vor aus herr
Scholz oder sagen Sie völkerrechtlich
ist eigentlich gedeckt dass die Ukraine
auch außerhalb ihres Territoriums
russische Stellungen angreifen darf
völkerrechtlich ist es völlig klar dass
alles was wir machen
zulässig ist
die Ukraine damit macht aber
gleichzeitig bleibt es auch immer
richtig klug zu sein und deshalb wäre es
nicht sehr klug wenn jetzt der mit den
Waffen die wir liefern zum Beispiel
Angriffe auf russisches Territorium
vorgetragen würden und das ist etwas wo
wir uns auch verständigt haben und einig
sind dass das nicht geschehen soll und
diese Verständigung haben sie mit den
US-Amerikanern und auch mit der
US-amerikanischen Regierung jetzt dass
es keine Eskalation geben soll in Bezug
auf russisches Territorium auch wenn die
Raketen jetzt eine größere Reichweite
haben
Stichwort Eskalation ich muss ja gar
nicht sehr viele Gespräche zitieren und
anführen ich kann mich darauf beziehen
dass der amerikanische Präsident der
übrigens wirklich jemand ist der sehr
klug in dieser ganz großen Krise handelt
das öffentlich gesagt hat in einem
Artikel den da in der Times geschrieben
hat und ich finde er hat damit ein sehr
klares Statement abgegeben und wir alle
agieren entsprechend sowieso es gibt
einen wichtigen in den USA the RAND
Corporation die schreiben diesen Krieg
keine absolut gewinnen Politiker im
Westen setzen auf einen Sieg der Ukraine
sie offensichtlich nicht wechseln diese
anderen Politiker verwechseln die das
Wünschenswerte mit dem möglichen
wir müssen unsere Möglichkeiten immer
genau betrachten und deshalb ist es so
dass wir genau schauen was können wir an
Unterstützung gewährleisten und ich habe
bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
sehr bewusst gesagt ganz offensichtlich
versucht putinen jetzt den Krieg in die
Länge zu ziehen in der Hoffnung dass
wenn er lange genug durchhält und
genügend
Opfer bringt und das sind ja wirklich
seine Bürgerinnen und Bürger deren Leben
er riskiert mit diesem Krieg das dann
irgendwann alle aufgeben aber das muss
unsere Botschaft sein das wird nicht
gelingen wir werden unsere Unterstützung
so lange durchhalten wie das notwendig
ist vielleicht führt das nur eben auch
einem zu einer ungewünschten
Solidarisierungseffekt in diesem
russischen Volk wir sind Herr stolz bei
der großen Frage wie China hatten sie
erwähnt da gibt es seit zwei Tagen
unangenehme Töne ehrlich gesagt
China stellt sich deutlich an die
komplette Putins was eigentlich wenn die
Chinesen jetzt doch Waffen liefern was
mit roten Linien ja aus allen Richtungen
begrenzt wurde ich habe auch bei meinen
letzten Gespräch mit
Vertretern Chinas klar gesagt dass das
nicht nicht akzeptiert werden kann und
ich war nicht der einzige das ist ja
auch das Gute an dieser Situation
öffentlich hat China auch erklärt keine
Waffen liefern zu wollen insofern ist es
wichtig dass wir da genau hinschauen und
das ist das was wir jetzt Vorhaben wir
sollten uns keine Illusion machen wir
sollten uns keine Illusion machen über
China die haben bisher nicht gegen
russlandstellung bezogen das war wichtig
dass der Einsatz von Atomwaffen klar
ausgeschlossen worden ist Vereinbarung
darauf sind sie eben auch zurecht stolz
oder werden es als einen Erfolg aber was
ist die heute noch wert
wir müssen jetzt sehen alles dafür tun
dass wir möglichst viele davon
überzeugen dass dieser Angriff den
Russland in Europa auf seinen
Nachbarland begonnen hat Angriff ist auf
die Friedensordnung die wir in der Welt
uns miteinander gegeben haben und dazu
gehört die Verständigung dass man nicht
mit gewaltgrenzen verschiebt das ist die
Grundlage dafür dass wir gut miteinander
leben können wenn alle so wie jetzt der
russische Präsident in Geschichtsbüchern
Blättern und daraus ihre eigenen
Schlüssel ziehen wo die Grenzen ihres
Landes am besten wären dann hätten wir
eine ganz lange Zeit von Krieg und
Unfrieden vor uns und deshalb müssen wir
gemeinsam in der Welt darauf bestehen
dass das nicht akzeptiert werden kann
gleichzeitig ist es so dass für viele
Länder in Asien in Afrika und im
Südamerikas der Krieg weit weg ist aber
die Konsequenzen unmittelbar spürbar
wenn es um Energiepreise und für viele
ja sogar Energie Sicherheit geht kommt
überhaupt was und das gleiche gilt für
Ernährungsfragen und deshalb war das und
bleibt das so wichtig dass wir ständig
mit vielen dieser Länder in Asien in
Afrika im Südamerikas sprechen Sie uns
noch mal eine Sekunde bei den USA
bleiben die USA machen im Grunde ja
jetzt auch eine sehr klare sehr
eindeutige neue China-Politik immer
wieder neue Sanktionen taiwanbesuche
Balance der Chinesen wurden mit Raketen
abgeschossen gehen Sie da auch so
konsequent wie sie das jetzt im Falle
Russland tun an der Seite der USA sagen
sie das was die USA da in China tut
sanktioniert bestraft machen wir auch
wir haben im Rahmenbedingungen ein
bisschen schwanger wir haben auch ein
Rahmen der G7 Entscheidung zu den Fragen
getroffen und uns werden uns auch weiter
über solche Fragen unterhalten ganz
wichtig ist dass wir von allen erwarten
dass sie sich an die internationale
Ordnung und die internationalen Regeln
halten und auch als ich in China war
habe ich diese Fragen angesprochen die
wichtig sind im Hinblick auf den Umgang
China ist mit seinen Nachbarn im
Hinblick auf den Umgang Chinas mit
Taiwan die USA und wir sind
verfolgen ein Konzept das nennt sich in
der internationalen Politik ein China
Politik aber dazu gehört aus unserer
Sicht auch dass wir sagen auch da darf
keine Gewalt eingesetzt werden und das
ist etwas worüber niemand mit sich
missverständlich ausdrücken meine Frage
war ob sie da genauso hat und genauso
überzeugt an der Seite der US-Amerikaner
sind China tatsächlich auch in
Sanktionen zu zwingen weil wir definitiv
abhängiger von ihnen sind oder ist die
Amerikaner von den Chinesen meine ich
halte nichts von den Dingen die jetzt
diskutiert werden die Globalisierung die
kapling ganz klar ist dass die der
Wiederaufstieg Asiens der gar nicht nur
China umfasst sondern auch viele andere
Länder Indonesien zum Beispiel wurde er
G20-Gipfel stattgefunden hat Indien wo
die nächste g20-konferenz sein wird dass
der Wiederaufstieg auch bedeutet dass
das relevante Orte der Welt sind mit
großer Wirtschaftskraft und nicht nur
großer Bevölkerung und wir werden
miteinander auskommen müssen aber gerade
deshalb auf der Einhaltung gemeinsam
gefunden da Regeln bestehen und das ist
das worum es geht in der Politik der
Zukunft das wird aus meiner Sicht eine
Welt sein mit vielen vielen mächtigen
Ländern viel mehr als wir das heute
kennen muss sie haben immer wieder
überzeugen muss und das ist auch meine
feste
Vorstellung wir dürfen jetzt nicht du
tun dass wir gewissermaßen gerade die
Zeit des Kolonialismus hinter uns
gelassen haben
und
dann anfangen können zu sagen was diese
Länder tun sollen weil wir jetzt neue
Vorstellungen haben sondern wir müssen
sie möchten diese Arroganz darf
überhaupt nicht auftreten sondern wir
müssen mit den Ländern die ihre eigenen
sichten ihre eigenen Perspektiven haben
reden und wenn wir das tun haben wir
auch eine gute Chance dass das eine Welt
wird nicht nur mit vielen mächtigen
Ländern sondern auch mit Ländern die
zusammenarbeiten und kooperieren und
meine
Arbeit geht auch dahin als ich mir das
den als ich den gezwang den g7-gipfel in
Deutschland ausgerichtet habe im Ellmau
habe ich bewusst zum Beispiel Indonesien
und Indien und Südafrika und Senegal und
Argentinien eingeladen und man Zeichen
zu setzen dass wir jetzt auf der Welt
anders miteinander zusammenarbeiten
wollen und übrigens auch zuhören in
Brasilien sind sie enttäuscht worden da
ist der Sozialdemokrat Scholz von dem
Demokraten Lula enttäuscht worden gerade
als es um die Sanktionen ging gegen
Russland und jetzt war sind sie morgen
auf dem Weg nach Neu-Delhi auch Indien
ja eigentlich ein unsicherer Kantonist
die in der unterlaufen die Sanktionen
sie kaufen russisches Öl und verkaufen
es teuer in Richtung Westen und
Westeuropa
befürchten sie das dann noch jemand den
Kopf schüttelt den sie gerade genannt
haben als einen
potenziellen Verbündeten
ich glaube
dass wenn wir von einem so großen Land
wie Indien als unsicheren Kantonisten
sprechen
nicht die richtige Haltung ist sondern
das geht schon darum dass wir uns auf
Augenhöhe miteinander verständigen und
das gehört auch zur Wahrheit dazu viele
Länder haben bei den
Resolutionen der Generalversammlung die
seit dem Beginn des Ukraine Krieges
beschlossen worden sind gegen den Krieg
gestimmt manche haben sich enthalten
aber von all denen die dort sich
enthalten haben hört man keineswegs dass
sie auf der Seite Russland stehen
sondern sie verurteilen den Krieg auch
und der brasilianische Präsident hat
genauso wie der indische
Ministerpräsident gesagt das ist ein
Krieg der nicht rechtfertigt ist das ist
dann nicht genau das was wir sagen und
deshalb bleiben wir am Ball miteinander
zu diskutieren aber es ist ein
Unterschied der da eine Rolle spielt und
dann finde ich sollten wir auch nicht
einfach drüber hinwegsehen es gibt nur
wenige Länder die auf der Seite
Russlands mitgestimmt haben heute wird
um den Text einer unfriesens Resolution
sehr gerungen unter anderem von ihrer
Außenministerin da gibt es eine
Feinabstimmung gerade und natürlich
zählt man schon wer zu den 50 Staaten
die sie unterschreiben wollen dann noch
hinzukommt die Außenministerin ist eine
Person über die wir unbedingt noch reden
müssen nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
die sollte auf dem Tisch legen herr
Scholz und die gibt es noch nicht weil
Anna-Lena baerbock einfach eine zu
wichtige Rolle darin haben möchte nein
es gibt überhaupt noch gar keine
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie das ist
die Innovation der Fortschritt den sich
die von mir geführte Regierung
vorgenommen hat und wir werden eine
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
beschließen bisher gibt es weißbücher
die beschlossen worden sind und dass wir
das so machen wie viele andere Länder
richtig eine
Sicherheitsstrategie zu formulieren die
sich nicht nur auf Fragen von der
Verteidigung oder der Außenpolitik
beschränkt sondern auch sicher in
Energie Fragen rohstoffversorgungsfragen
ökonomische Fragen mit einbezieht
Entwicklungshilfe Fragestellung
diskutiert das ist das was wir machen
werden und sie sind kurz davor das
fertig zu kriegen wer diese
Koordinierung diese
besonderen Stelle des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates eben führen wird die
Außenministerin hat ohnehin
offensichtlich hörbar das Gefühl dass
sie an manchen Stellen ein bisschen zu
nachgiebig sind und das schauen wir uns
auch noch mal an
das Problem ist im Kanzleramt
die deutsche Außenpolitik zwischen
Crescendo und Andante die Dissonanzen
zwischen grüner Außenministerin und
SPD-Kanzler unüberhörbar
zuletzt bei der kampfpanzerdebatte
ich wollte eigentlich als Leopard kommen
aber dann hatte ich doch Sorgen dass wir
das Kanzleramt wochenlang keine
Reisegenehmigung erteilt
volle Rückendeckung von der grünen
Spitze für die Außenministerin
entsprechend sollte Deutschland sich
nicht in den Weg stellen wenn andere
Länder Entscheidungen treffen die
Ukraine zu unterstützen ich weiß nicht
warum Schützenpanzer nicht eskalativ
sind aber Kampfer schon
das sind nicht irgendwelche Kollegen der
Grünen sondern Spitzenpolitiker das
sagen sie sicherlich auch Herr Scholz
Annalena bärbock setzte sich vor ihnen
so schreiben dass die Zeit und der
Spiegel in London für den Kampfpanzer
ein sie setzte sich in Paris in einem
Interview für die Genehmigung der
Kampfpanzer für die Polen ein ist sie
ihnen ein bisschen zu forscht nein und
ich fand auch den Auftritt beim Karneval
sehr lustig zu sagen darf weil ich finde
man muss ja auch mit dieser
Medienbericht statt Erstattung irgendwie
locker umgehen denn tatsächlich ist es
so dass wir sicherlich andere und
unterschiedliche Persönlichkeiten sind
aber sehr eng miteinander abgestimmt
sind eng kooperieren alle Sachen
gemeinsam vorbereiten
Scholz Annalena Werbung haben sie ihren
Kabinettsmitgliedern vorher bescheid
gesagt wir haben das sorgfältig
miteinander vorbrochen und wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass nichts nach außen
dringt und wir haben auch den Zeitpunkt
der Bekanntmachung sehr sorgfältig
festgelegt denn wegen der Zeitdifferenz
zwischen den USA und Deutschland war es
nicht möglich dass wir das morgens um 9
Uhr tun weil dann wäre da noch dunkle
Nacht gewesen und haben deshalb genau
den Zeitpunkt festgelegt wo wir das
bekannt machen ich glaube ungefähr 11
Uhr und natürlich waren alle die es
angeht da eingebunden warum beklagen
sich denken Sie diese ihr Vizekanzler
immerhin macht die gleiche Bemerkung und
wünscht sich eben anderen Ländern nicht
im Wege zu stehen wir erinnern uns auch
an den Zeitpunkt warum sagt um mit
nuripur so etwas ist das
von ihnen irgendwie toleriert finden Sie
das auch gut dass die im Grunde genommen
sie an manchen Stellen da auch in der
Öffentlichkeit ein bisschen wie soll ich
sagen schubsen schauen Sie wir haben
jetzt seit einem Jahr diesen furchtbaren
Krieg der hat dazu geführt dass in
Deutschland und ich habe das drei Tage
nach Kriegsausbruch in einer Rede im
Deutschen Bundestag angekündigt alles
anders gemacht wird als viele Jahrzehnte
zuvor und dass wir ein Sondervermögen
Schaffen von 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr dass wir zukünftig zwei
Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
Verteidigung ausgeben dass wir Waffen in
einem Kriegsgebiet liefern das wäre all
diese Dinge tun das ist natürlich etwas
was nicht nur überall im Land diskutiert
wird sondern auch von denjenigen die mit
ganzem Herzen Politik machen und jetzt
diese Regierung tragen aber wichtig ist
dass wir gemeinsam handeln und ich
glaube dass spätestens mit der
Entscheidung die wir jetzt getroffen
haben eng abgestimmt mit den USA dass
wir auch Kampfpanzer liefern was der
richtige Zeitpunkt war und die richtige
Vorgehensweise das nicht nur öffentlich
so gesehen wird dass das eine sehr
erfolgreiche Strategie ist die sich eben
nicht drängen lässt von öffentlichen
Diskursen sondern von der Sach
Notwendigkeit getrieben wird und dass
das ja auch seine Wirkung hat also diese
Regierung ist es gemeinsam die den Kurs
verfolgt über den wir hier schon seit
einiger Zeit miteinander reden
Krisenzeiten sind
kommunikationszeiten da muss noch viel
mehr und noch viel
ausführlicher vielleicht das wäre die
Frage kommuniziert werden wir haben ein
paar Kollegen gefragt wie sie ihre
Kommunikation einschätzen
die Kommunikation ist beim Kanzler der
Schwachpunkt seiner Politik ich möchte
da die drei großen es nennen das ist
Empathie das ist Erklärung und das ist
Emotionalität von allem drei begriffen
hat er leider zu wenig vor allen Dingen
er sagt was er will und er sagt auch wie
er es will aber leider erklärt er zu
wenig warum was Scholz tut ist gar nicht
so fern von dem was zum Beispiel Merkel
kommunikativ getan hat es fällt aber auf
weil es mittlerweile Akteure gibt dies
ganz anders handhaben zum Beispiel
Robert Habeck der kommuniziert immer
seine Zweifel mit und seine Abwägung
oder Frau bärbock die kommuniziert immer
ihre Gefühle mit und das tut Scholz
nicht Scholz ist leise in seinen
Aussagen ist zurückhaltend ergreift sehr
selten an und er polarisiert nicht das
kann man gut oder schlecht finden aber
in Umbruchzeiten erwarten die Leute
einen klarere Haltung und vielleicht
auch mal eine Position diese ablehnen
können oder dass sie sich anschließen
können er gehört zu den Politikern die
denken es lohnt sich erst zu sprechen
wenn eine Entscheidung gefallen ist und
das was zu verkünden gibt das führt
immer zu diesen langen schweigephasen zu
diesen Phasen der Unsicherheit alle
sprechen Olaf schweigt und keiner weiß
wo will der Kanzler eigentlich hin im
Nachhinein sagt er dann immer das war
Teil einer großen Strategie und eines
großen Plans meine Vermutung ist dass es
sehr oft keinen Plan gibt und dass da
aus dem Schweigen eine Tugend gemacht
wird hinter der sich versteckt
es wäre im Übrigen auch keine
verwunderliche Tatsache herr Scholz dass
man nicht immer einen Plan haben kann
aber sie kommunizieren tatsächlich ist
das so gewünscht sie kommunizieren Dinge
in einer Ausführlichkeit immer erst wenn
Sie entschieden sind machen sie das ganz
bewusst so sind jetzt ja doch ein paar
Aussagen gefallen die ich unterstreichen
könnte weil ich fand das eigentlich eine
treffende und aus meiner Sicht ja auch
bestätigende Beschreibung dessen was ich
versuche in dieser Situation umzugehen
ich halte nichts davon dass man in einer
so ernsten Angelegenheit wie diesen
furchtbaren Krieg der jetzt in Europa
begonnen hat bei Russland die Ukraine
überfallen hat irgendwie jede Woche eine
andere Meinung verkündet das kann man
ganz lustig inszenieren und es gibt auch
einige Politiker in Deutschland die
dafür bekannt sind dass sie jede Woche
eine andere Meinung haben aber die mit
großer Kraft ich glaube das ist nicht
richtig hier und es ist auch nicht gut
für die Akzeptanz der Entscheidung es
ist gerade weil die BürgerInnen und
dieses Landes unsicher sein müssen
angesichts der Gefahren die mit diesem
Krieg verbunden sind es ist nicht gut
wenn Sie das Gefühl haben der
Regierungschef muss ständig das was er
gesagt hat widerrufen weil er
gewissermaßen einem
Unterhaltungsprogramm dass die Medien ja
auch darstellen Folgen irgendwie ständig
was dazu sagen erklären sie hinreichend
worüber sie sich Sorgen erklären sie
hinreichend warum sie auf bestimmte
Partner in Europa länger warten mussten
erklären sie ihr besonderes Verhältnis
zu Immanuel macron der ja mit Ihnen
gemeinsam auch erst nach vier Monaten
Herren selenski besuchte anderes mehr
erklären sie das den Menschen damit es
verständlich ist und vielleicht auch
nicht missinterpretiert werden kann eben
als ein da ist jemand zurückhaltend da
will jemand nicht so richtig so wenig
wird gar nicht geredet ich glaube in
ihrer Sendung bin ich jetzt das dritte
mal das ist sehr viel mehr als sie das
von früheren Kanzlerin und Kanzlerin
mitbekommen haben und das gilt auch für
viele viele andere
Wege der öffentlichen Kommunikation Erbe
Reden zu diesen Themen gehalten in den
all die Fragen die sie gestellt haben
auch erörtert werden und wo klare
Festlegungen getroffen werden aber es
ist mir wichtig es ist mir wichtig dass
hier wirklich alle begreifen das geht
nicht darum wie man zur nächsten
Pressekonferenz marschiert sondern darum
dass wir dafür sorgen dass der Frieden
und die Sicherheit in Europa gewahrt
bleiben und dass wir die Sicherheit
unseres Landes verteidigen sie haben in
einem Bürgergespräch gesagt herr Scholz
ich erwähnte das schon in Interviews
würden sie nach diese eskalationsgefahr
und nach der Wichtigkeit von Diplomatie
nie gefragt halten sie das war in
Marburg halten sie Journalisten für
kriegslöstern
na ich will jedenfalls berichten dass
man den vielen Burger Gesprächen die ich
führe ich
überwiegend anders befragt werde als das
öffentlich stattfindet aber wir hatten
mit Bürgern in der Sendung jedes Mal
kommt in einem solchen Bürgergespräch
irgendeiner und meldet oder eine und
meldet sich zu Wort und sagt dann den
Satz wer hat eigentlich die Idee
erfunden dass man mit Waffen Frieden
schaffen kann da klatschen immer 20 bis
30 Prozent und das kann man ja auch in
den Meinungsumfragen ein bisschen
wiederfinden das ist ein Teil der
Bevölkerung gibt die skeptisch sind und
den antworte ich auf diesen
Veranstaltungen weil ich sage man kann
ein Land wie die Ukraine nicht alleine
lassen wenn es von einem so großen
mächtigen Gegner angegriffen wird muss
es unterstützen damit wir Frieden und
Sicherheit in Europa
gewährleisten können das ist unsere
Aufgabe denn wenn jemand sagt macht geht
vor recht dann ist es ja klar dass er
das wenn es einmal geklappt hat
vielleicht auch beim sie möchten nichts
überstürzen fühlen Sie sich von einer
schweigenden Mehrheit getragen herr
Scholz ich fühle mich von einer großen
Mehrheit getragen und das wird mir immer
deutlich in den Gesprächen die ich mit
Bürgern und Bürgern führe ich habe jetzt
eine Frage genannt es gibt auch alle
anderen Fragen auch hier erörtert werden
und mein Eindruck ist es gibt viele
Bürger und Bürger die sind sich nicht
sicher ob wir nicht zu weit gehen also
die sagen mit den Sanktionen und mit den
Waffen die von ist das nicht ein
bisschen viel aber ich bin überzeugt
davon dass ein großer Teil dieser Bürger
und Bürger gerade weil wir nicht schnell
gesprochene sondern gut abgewogene mit
verbündeten beredete
Entscheidung treffen trotzdem Vertrauen
haben dass die Regierung das schon
vernünftig
handeln wird das gilt sowieso für
diejenigen die diesen abgewogenen Kurs
genau richtig finden aber auch unter
denjenigen die vielleicht für sich
selber sagen sie würden gerne das eine
oder andere anders schneller ein
bisschen mehr machen wissen dass das
natürlich
trotzdem richtig ist sich mit anderen
abzusprechen und das sorgfältig
vorzubereiten was wir entscheiden und
deshalb glaube ich ja es gibt eine
übergroße Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die damit einverstanden ist dass
wir so vorgehen wie wir das tun
600.000 Unterschriften haben
einen Aufruf von Sarah Wagenknecht und
all diese schwarze gefunden die
Tageszeitung hat hier in Berlin findet
diesen Aufruf amoralisch
ich teile
die Überzeugung dieses Aufrufs nicht
habe ich eben schon gesagt und ist ja
auch die Praxis meiner Regierungspolitik
ihr liefern ja Waffen und unterstützen
die Ukraine das kommt übrigens in dem
Aufruf auch mit vor dass klar gesagt
wird das ist ein Angriff aber es reicht
nicht weil wenn man sagt wie das der
Aufruf gut ist muss jetzt Verhandlungen
geben dann ist das ja
nichts was irgendwie weiterführt wenn
wir
verstehen müssen dass der russische
Präsident gegenwärtig nur eine Form von
Verhandlungen akzeptiert nämlich dass
irgendjemand bedingungslos kapituliert
und er alle seine Ziele durchsetzt der
Moment der eine friedensperspektive
eröffnet der muss erst entstehen und das
ist der Grund warum ich zum Beispiel
auch immer wieder
zuletzt im Dezember aber irgendwann
demnächst auch mal wieder mit dem
russischen Präsidenten reden werde um
ihm vorzutragen dass die Dinge anders
sind als sie von ihm gesehen werden und
zu hoffen dass dann irgendwann ein
Moment entsteht wo dann tatsächlich
faire Gespräche möglich sind die für die
ukrainere und Ukraine zu akzeptablen
richtigen Ergebnissen führen vielleicht
sind die Deutschen auch kriegsmüde und
kriegsmüde herr Scholz wie groß ist ihre
Sorge dass wir in einem Jahr hier wieder
sitzen könnten und dieser Krieg immer
noch nicht zu Ende ist
ganz offen das ist eine meiner größten
Sorgen dass das jetzt ein sehr lange
sich hinziehender Krieg wird mit
unglaublichen Zerstörung und Verlusten
und
deshalb dürfen wir auch nicht nachlassen
darin
zu versuchen dass das anders kommt aber
eine Voraussetzung dafür ist eben die
Erklärung und Bereitschaft die Ukraine
so lange zu unterstützen wie das
notwendig ist und das haben wir gesagt
und das tun wir
vertrauen Sie mir sagte die
Bundeskanzlerin die sie in direkt schon
angesprochen haben und sie sagen auch
vertrauen Sie mir warum sind das nach
der letzten forscherumfrage nur 41
Prozent und warum sagen 25 sie 25
Prozent halten sie nur für führungsfähig
das ist eine ganz aufgeregt Zeit für
viele mit einer wirklich fruchtbaren
Bedrohung wie wir sie seit dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges in Europa so noch
nicht erlebt haben und das ist für ganz
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger wirklich
und zu Recht ja eine ganz schwierige
Zeit und das was ich mir fest
vorgenommen habe das ist dass ich in
dieser Zeit das Richtige tue das was ich
selber für richtig halte dass ich mich
nicht drängeln lasse dass ich nicht
falsche überstürzte Entscheidung treffe
dass ich keine Dinge tue die
hinterher alle Bedauern sondern dass ich
fest
dafür Sorge dass wir unsere
Unterstützung gewährleisten können und
dass sich gleichzeitig dafür Sorge dass
unser Land diese schwierige Zeit gut
übersteht wir haben ja auch manches
erreicht was einige sicher vorhergesagt
haben dass es uns nicht gelingen wird in
ihrer Sendung zum Beispiel ist im
letzten Jahr vorher gesagt von von
manchen ihrer Gesprächsteilnehmer das
ist gut Winter und wutherbste geben wird
dass wir es kalt haben dass die
Energieversorgung unseres Landes nicht
gewährleistet ist dass wir eine
Wirtschaftskrise haben und alles haben
wir vermieten mit großem Einsatz aber es
spricht ein bisschen dafür dass wir
schon einen sehr
vernünftigen Kurs in einer ganz
schwierigen Zeit eingeschlagen werden
dahin marschieren wir jetzt immer mit
der Frage empfinden die Menschen das sie
diesen sehr schwierigen Prozess nämlich
eine multi-krise gut führen es ist
interessant dass sie das Erwähnen lassen
Demonstrationen sind noch vorher gesagt
worden Blackouts hat es auch nicht
gegeben
und Gas ist zur Verfügung auch das ist
der Regierung gelungen aber sie erinnern
sich Herr Scholz dass es gerade auch
ihre Kabinettsmitglieder waren die
diesen Teufel an die Wand gemalt haben
also es waren eben auch Annalena
baerbock die von Volksaufständen sprach
und Robert Habeck der die den sozialen
Frieden in diesem Land im Sommer in
Gefahr sah
da müsste man sich dann bei denen auch
beklagen dass die Voraussagen getroffen
oder Aussagen gemacht haben wenigstens
wo man sich als Bürger ein bisschen
wunderte ich beklage mich bei überhaupt
niemanden der sich Sorgen gemacht hat
und die auch zum Ausdruck gebracht hat
das gilt ja auch für viele Bürgerinnen
und
bürgerkanzler und die Außenminister
Sorgen gemacht haben das ist doch
überhaupt nicht verwunderlich die Frage
die wichtig ist ist schaffen wir es
geschafft den Sorgen zu begegnen indem
wir das richtige getan haben und weil
das alles ausgeblieben ist was einige
befötet haben kann man sagen irgendwie
wahrscheinlich schon und das hat ja auch
große Anstrengungen erfordert ich habe
schon bevor der Krieg ausgebrochen ist
mit dem Wirtschaftsminister und mein
wirtschaftlichen Berater darüber
gesprochen was eigentlich passiert wenn
Russland die Gaslieferung einstellt und
deshalb waren wir vorbereitet als der
Krieg begann die notwendigen
Entscheidung zu treffen und hätten wir
das nicht getan hätten wir die
gastspeicher nicht gefüllt hätten wir
nicht die Kraftwerke wieder laufen
lassen die abgeschaltet waren hätten wir
nicht auch die Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen lassen bis in den April
diesen Jahres hätten wir nicht dafür
gesorgt dass wir Gast aus aller Welt
bekommen auch über neu zu bauende
Terminals an den norddeutschen Küsten
werden wir jetzt in anderen Lage also
haben manche Menschen auch die Nerven
verloren herr Scholz weil ihre Regierung
vier Monate gebraucht hat oben aus einer
unseligen gasumlage dann endlich eine
gaspreisbremse zu machen konnte man
darüber auch verzweifeln wir haben sehr
früh angefangen alles dafür zu tun dass
wir die Situation gewährleistet dass wir
die Sicherheit gewährleisten können und
wir haben am Ende 300 Milliarden Euro
eingesetzt um die Krise die auf uns
zugekommen ist
zu bekämpfen und das ist gelungen
noch mal die Frage ist hat eine Zeit
lang gebraucht und es gab eine große
Verunsicherung es hat keine
versorgungsnot gegeben die Menschen
haben jetzt mit höheren Preisen zu tun
Preissteigerung im Januar Strom 45
Prozent im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
Gas 24 Prozent und manche wissen noch
gar nicht von den vor allen Dingen von
den Mietern ob das dicke Ende noch kommt
und wie viel da insgesamt auf sie
zukommt werden die Menschen verstanden
haben dass Energie teuer bleibt und dass
wir damit natürlich auch inklusive der
Inflation weniger Geld zur Verfügung
haben zunächst mal sind die 200
Milliarden von den 300 die wir
eingesetzt haben um Preise herunter zu
subventionieren
auf dem Tisch und wir haben die Gesetze
beschlossen mit denen das auch passieren
kann so dass wir wenn das alles jetzt im
Einzelnen umgesetzt ist auch eine
Stützung vornehmen eine Stützung
vornehmen können und das ist für viele
dann eine große Entlastung und Sie
müssen sich dann sich immer noch
bekümmern das ist ja offensichtlich wenn
alles teurer wird aber es ist eben
anders als hätten wir all die Dinge
nicht gemacht die wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben und da wird ja manches
noch von greifen insofern glaube ich
kann man sagen wir können gefasst dieser
Situation entgegengehen aber die höheren
Preise bleiben ein Problem und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt alles dafür tun dass
wir die Möglichkeiten die wir haben
geringere Energiepreise durchzusetzen
auch nutzen weil die Börsen spielen
gerade ein anderes Lied wie wollen Sie
das ist eine nächste wirklich wichtige
Frage weil es die Menschen eben auch
bewegt die wollen Sie sicherstellen und
verhindern dass Energieversorger
ist jetzt nicht an diesen
Hilfsmilliarden bereichern während die
sie stützen im Grunde genommen jetzt
einen Preis der niedriger geworden ist
an den Börsen die Versorger lassen
ziemlich intransparent was davon jetzt
an den Kunden weitergegeben wird und was
sie aber auch einfach nutzen um
Preiserhöhungen so zu lassen oder eben
nur zum Teil zu minimieren ganz präzise
Frage wie wollen Sie vermeiden dass sich
Versorger jetzt einen goldenen
Winter machen erstens wäre es völlig
unmoralisch wenn das passiert ist und
deshalb das gibt's manchmal und das
haben wir gesetzgeberische Vorkehrungen
getroffen das bundeskartelland wird
seine Aufgaben wahrnehmen aber wir haben
auch sichergestellt dass nicht durch
Einkaufspreise
gerechtfertigte Preissteigerung auch
angegriffen werden können von
öffentlichen Institutionen das ist Teil
der Gesetzgebung die wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben die Bundesnetzagentur hat
schon mal gesagt sie hat diese
Kontrollbefugnis nicht das heißt das
müsste dann nur über das Kartellamt
laufen wir haben jedenfalls erstmal die
Kontrollmöglichkeit geschaffen und wir
werden auch hinterhergehen für einige
wird das ja die Möglichkeit geben dass
sie wechseln können für andere nicht und
da ist es dann wichtig dass wir
kontrollieren dass niemand die Situation
jetzt ausnutzt das kann man nicht
hinnehmen ich will aber doch noch mal
wenn Sie das gestatten kurz zurückkommen
zu dem was wir vorher am Wickel hatten
wir werden jetzt nicht sagen alles ist
getan wir legen die Hände in den Schoß
sondern wir werden weiter dafür sorgen
dass unsere Import Infrastrukturen
verbessert werden so dass wir den Ersatz
der ausbleibenden Lieferung von Kohle Öl
und Gas aus Russland auch tatsächlich
gut hinkriegen dass wir genügend
Kapazitäten haben das hat also jetzt
nicht aufgehört und bleibt auch die
Aufgabe dieses und des nächsten das
dafür zu sorgen und wir bauen
gleichzeitig die erneuerbaren Energien
aus die die Grundlage dafür bieten dass
wir auf Dauer billigere Stromversorgung
billigere Energieversorgung das ist das
Riesenproblem hatten sie ursprünglich
verabredet herr Scholz im
Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich zeitgleich
hinzukriegen sie wollten sanieren was da
ist und sie wollten diese diesen
riesigen Umbau der Wirtschaft
hinbekommen bis zum Jahre 2014 ich muss
Ihnen nicht sagen wie Wissenschaftler da
heute drauf gucken also energieökonomen
die sagen täglich müssten wir jetzt fünf
Windräder bauen und zwar täglich in den
nächsten zehn Jahren um unseren dann
Strom betraf herzustellen
momentan sind sechs Jahre pro Windrad
mit insgesamt 23 Aktenordnern also da
braucht es noch ein bisschen von dieser
deutschland-geschwindigkeit werden wir
das schaffen auch in Anbetracht dieser
Krise
und deshalb hat er nicht nur
Wissenschaftler davon gesprochen sondern
ich das öffentlich gesagt und da wo es
vor dem ganzen wirtschaftspublikum und
bei vielen anderen Gelegenheiten auch in
Interviews in reden wir arbeiten
gegenwärtig genau dem Planen aus was
brauchen wir an zusätzlichen
Windkraftanlagen an Land auf hoher See
solarmöglichkeiten mit Solarenergie
Strom zu erzeugen wie müssen wir unsere
Stromnetz ausbauen und ändern alle
Gesetze die dazu erforderlich sind die
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit die wir an
den Tag gelegt haben beim Bau der
flüssiggasthandels an den norddeutschen
Küsten die soll jetzt auch für viele
viele andere Bereiche gelten und wir
haben
im letzten Jahr bereits mit mehreren
gesetzespaketen viele der
Schwierigkeiten abgeschafft die in der
Vergangenheit gegolten haben und wir
haben für dieses Jahr weitere
gesetzliche Maßnahmen vor die genau das
bewirken sollen denn das wird die größte
Veränderung seit vielleicht Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts was das industrielle
Geschehen in Deutschland betrifft
irgendwie parallel passieren und sie
werden dann auch sehr viele überzeugen
müssen was der Bürger auch zur Kenntnis
nimmt und das ist meine letzte Frage
herr Scholz ist dass sich in ihrem
Kabinett im Grunde die zentralen
Minister alle auch gut streiten es gibt
einen öffentlichen Briefverkehr zwischen
dem Vizekanzler und dem Finanzminister
es gibt Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
anderen Ministerien die auch SPD geführt
sind man hatte den Eindruck dass es nun
auch gerade in Bezug auf die Steuern und
den Haushalt eine große
Auseinandersetzung gibt darüber wo man
noch mehr Geld ausgeben muss und es wird
nicht möglich sein die Kinder
Grundsicherung 12 Milliarden plus die
Bedürfnisse von Herrn historius Plus an
Sie werden sich entscheiden müssen
der Finanzminister sagt auf gar keinen
Fall Steuererhöhungen Herr herber die
sich was sagt Herr Scholz
das haben drei Parteien eine Regierung
gebildet die unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen haben aber alle für den
Fortschritt in Deutschland eintreten wir
haben uns viele Dinge vorgenommen die
wir in dieser Legislaturperiode
erreichen wollen waren aber es gibt ja
andere wichtige Bedürfnisse und wir
werden diese Vorhaben auch in dieser
Legislaturperiode alle anpacken da bin
ich ganz sicher ich glaube dass was wir
gerade erleben ist dass es richtig darum
geht vieles besser zu machen sehr sehr
viel besser zu machen aber ich
persönlich bin ja wie sie in der ich bin
ja persönlich wie sie in dieser Sendung
mehrfach auch dargestellt haben jemand
der nicht jeden Tag zu allem was
kommentieren sagt aber ich wundere mich
jedenfalls nicht wenn es ab und zu auch
ein paar Geräusche gibt wenn man so viel
arbeitet ja neue Schulden noch mehr
Schulden oder höhere Steuern
das gingen nur das wünscht sich die SPD
und die Grünen das ginge nur ohne
Christian Lindner da wäre der nicht
dabei der Finanzminister haben eine
Koalition und wir haben das was wir tun
werden in den Koalitionsvertrag
geschrieben dazu zählt auch eine
Verständigung über unsere
Haushaltspolitik und dazu zählt eine
Verständigung über unsere Steuerpolitik
und über viele sehr wichtige soziale
Vorhaben einschließlich der massiven
Modernisierung unserer Volkswirtschaft
damit wir auch in 10 20 30 Jahren noch
gute Arbeitsplätze haben und wir werden
uns entlang der Verständigung die wir
haben miteinander bewegen bleiben drei
Parteien aber es gilt das was wir in
unsere Verträge geschrieben haben und
daran orientiere ich mich als Kanzler
keine Steuererhöhungen also und ich
danke Herr Bundeskanzler für dieses
Gespräch heute abend dass wir drei
Minuten überzogen haben und deshalb noch
ein bisschen schneller zu Markus Lanz
übergeben für die Zuschauer des heutigen
Abends der unter anderem Norbert Röttgen
zu Gast hat
[Musik]